hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe and in one form it falls
from the heavens and splashes on the
ground held in water as H2O
and that stream of tiny bubbles is pure
hydrogen on the other pencil there's a
little bit of oxygen coming off as well
and this is just by adding electricity
to water so in some ways making hydrogen
is pretty simple
away from the lab and closer to the
forecourt the same chemistry is
happening here here we have our hydrogen
electrolyzer that produces our green
hydrogen on-site and in here is the
process room we take tap water straight
from the mains and purify it using this
unit here
it's making hydrogen to deliver just
over the wall to a filling station you
can refuel in a couple of minutes get a
range of over 300 miles and all that's
emitted is a little water as the
hydrogen and oxygen recombine
really nice car quick quiet and a decent
range but the problem for hydrogen cars
is the number of fueling stations only
around 11 public hydrogen points around
the country whereas for their competitor
for the future electric cars 50 000 plus
and also there's the opportunity to
charge them at home
so while private cars are turning to the
electric highway it's the big boys who
are hitching up to a hydrogen future
buses especially where cities are
driving down air pollution and
construction vehicles as Builders seek
to hit low-carbon targets
our business model for now is to go more
into trucks buses and fleets that return
to base because we can have one
refueling site hydrogen is also being
touted as a new jet fuel this week
Rolls-Royce trialed a hydrogen jet
engine albeit on the ground
and steel making also has its eye on the
H but these are both massive energy
users and hydrogen is bound by some
inconvenient facts of physics breaking
it from oxygen in water requires huge
amounts of energy which to be climate
friendly must come from low carbon
sources like wind or nuclear already
much in demand
it's also harder to handle than fuels we
know you can't carry it in a can the
tiny H2 molecule can leak out of
existing gas pipe work and it's
incredibly voluminous this tank can hold
just 32 kilos the weight of a large dog
enough to fuel up just 30 cars
one company has developed a cunning new
way of using hydrogen that doesn't need
a whole new fueling ecosystem and it can
even work on your classic old white van
Tom do you want to put the bunny up and
see what's under there well it looks
just the same as any other diesel engine
I've opened up well practically it is
and it does and it should the only
difference really with this is it has a
couple of extra components we've got a
plate type generator which generates a
hydrogen on demand in the engine and a
control box there's not even headline
terms what do you think it delivers for
us well it dramatically improves the
emissions of an existing Fleet of
vehicles so so you know the benefits are
there on the existing Vehicles rather
than having to replace and renew at huge
costs this technology is far from zero
carbon but fusion blue aren't the only
ones who believe the near future for
hydrogen is as an additive this lab is
working towards adding hydrogen to big
lorry engines with a one million pound
test engine with a special quartz glass
cylinder allowing researchers to analyze
how different mixes of fuel affect
combustion and reduce emissions we want
to use zero carbon fuel in existing
engine so that we can have a much faster
immediate carbon reduction for transport
sector so we need to look at the
hydrogen combustion process to help
improve the hydrogen engine efficiency
hydrogen may have a bright future but as
a regular fuel it's a long way off